[Musique]
on attend d'écouter le premier single de
lisandro c'est une exclusivité les
chéris lisandru tullaye je l'enregistré
cette nuit non non hier nous il ya
longtemps nuit parce que après the
wackids nuit là quand même jamais
personne n'écoute et n'ont jamais là ça
va être une grosse à une grosse surprise
quoi j'ai alors moi j'ai peur parce que
voilà ça fait un peu flipper de voir que
je vais moins dressa et que les gens
vont réagir sur surplace quoi alors vous
allez recevoir le titre de lisandro donc
le gagnant de the voice mon lisandro on
écoute c'est parti
[Musique]
je connais ton histoire mais j'ai jamais
jamais jamais marché sur ta plage
j'ai grandi ségo
[Musique]
j'avais nous
et d'autres paysages
[Musique]
à
un jour te promets
[Musique]
ou assumer
réponse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
car
et
ces nouveaux tripoli
ah j'adore tabarez
oh
lisandro lisandro lisandro ni solo
richard neeson
[Applaudissements]
c'est en exclusivité le type le premier
single dani sordo alors ce taudis
c'est un tuba à sais pas ce qui va se
passer mais en tout cas en lançant ce
titre en pro enfin en tant que pour mes
singles c'était vraiment pour que tout
le monde cet été dense comme des oufs
quoi là on va danser
et puis c'est à dire je te ferait danser
ouais je vais fera danser du tout avancé
de 7 4 vous avez aimé ou pas le type 2
sont franchement j'ai adoré